hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my review of How to Train Your
Dragon 2 I think it's only a coincidence
that Kit Harington
is in both this movie and the game of
Thrones finale this weekend but it made
it a whole lot more fun to watch so
because most of you probably haven't
seen the movie yet I'm gonna start with
my non-spoilery review then I'm gonna do
my top 5 moments and talk about the
sequels because they're gonna do four
movies that's right originally was gonna
be a trilogy now it's gonna be four
movies so if you're finding me for the
first time I'm just doing a bunch of big
summer movie reviews just because we're
in the middle of summer movie season be
sure to subscribe to get everything
next up is 22 Jump Street and
transformers it's like a whole summer of
sequels and normally that's not good
news
a lot of sequels in the past two just
turned up the explosions till 11 at the
expense of the characters but one of my
favorite things about How to Train Your
Dragon was how it changed the characters
especially toothless hiccups Night Fury
going into the movie I actually knew
they'd be doing two more so I kept
wondering how they were gonna set those
up but I'll talk about that during
spoilers like I said kid Harrington
joined the cast Cate Blanchett and
Djimon Honsou of all the newcomers Cate
Blanchett was obviously the best but
that's not really fair kid Harrington
does a lot better whenever you can see
him and gimon haesu's character the
villain isn't quite up to turbo
wreckit-ralph standards so in case you
didn't know these movies are based on a
series of books by Cressida Cowell but
the movies are written by Dean de Blois
so whenever they like the first movie so
much it did so well they asked him to
write more he said I'm only gonna do it
if I can do a trilogy like my favorite
trilogy star wars so if this feels like
Empire Strikes Back that's why because
he specifically mentioned Empire Strikes
Back when he was talking about star wars
original trilogy I actually didn't know
that when I went to see it but now
looking back on it I do kind of think of
them being up in the north is looking
like Hoth and all the missing limbs
being like Luke getting his hand cut off
it kind of makes me wonder if the third
film will feel like return to the Jedi
which I totally don't mind so the Empire
Strikes Back How to Train Your Dragon
really takes that idea of trying to
learn more about your enemies it just
turns that way up obviously Djimon
Honsou character being the villain in
this case the story definitely went to a
much darker place than the first film I
would have liked to learn a lot more
about Djimon Honsou character drago
bludvist the movie is only about an hour
and forty minutes long so it almost
feels short enough to be a
tv/movie I don't know if any of you have
seen it but DreamWorks actually does a
TV show called dragon riders of Berk
it's a TV show based on the first movie
it only stars a couple people from the
movies so most of the main cast aren't
in it the other really big improvement
that I thought was awesome was the
animation in this movie just because
technology evolves so fast it was a lot
like them demoing games like Dragon Age
at e3 with graphics that upses were just
disgusting so your face just melts off
it looks so beautiful
it gave them the ability to make
toothless the dragon move in some really
new fun ways the Dragons are one of the
biggest actors in the movies and their
performances are completely dependent
upon the animation so I thought they did
a really awesome job so definitely go
see this movie but after you do make
sure you watch the Game of Thrones
finale this weekend just for some meta
Kit Harington moments so time to get in
spoilers I'm gonna talk about my top 5
moments and then I'll talk about where
some of the sequels are going so careful
if you haven't seen the movie yet but
here we go number 5 hiccup is building a
map this is gonna be the device that
takes them through those future sequels
it's like parts of the Caribbean 3
whenever they yanked out the map at the
end hiccup is gonna continue to chart
the known world they even said it in the
movie with dragons around the world just
got a whole lot bigger technically it
should have been that dragons allow them
to travel farther so the world is
getting smaller but you get the idea
their world in the first movie was just
that little island of Berk so now
they're just gonna continue to travel
further and further meet new characters
and these new sequels number 4 the Alpha
Sanctuary definitely the coolest new
location in the movie I know I said the
writer was inspired by the Star Wars
trilogy but I also saw a lot of Star
Trek Roth accom whenever they entered
that cave he meets his mother they
traveled to ice planet hoth but she
takes him inside her secret garden cave
like Carol Marcus in Wrath of Khan I
totally love it when cartoons and
animation pay homage to my favorite
science fiction stories especially when
they don't feel corny and I felt like
they did a really good job of doing that
in this movie especially that big reveal
moment whenever hiccup sees all the
dragons for the first time and they're
just flying in formation around that
giant ice pillar meeting the Alpha was
pretty cool too he was definitely a big
upgrade from the mega dragon in that
first movie number 3 hiccup starts to
learn more dragon lore there were a ton
of new things the movie taught us about
dragons and controlling dragons it seems
like as we go forward his mother Cate
Blanchett is going to be teach
a lot of these things I did get a really
big game of Thrones flash from season
three with that control rod that
Daenerys got that controled her
unsullied army hiccups mom and drago
bludvist both had those you know dragon
control staff so presumably hiccups
gonna learn to use something like that
in the next movie there were a few big
questions I had after they started using
those staffs for instance if Drago was
doing the same thing as hiccups mom why
couldn't she command the evil alpha like
Drago part of the story was about
bonding with dragons on a really deep
level as opposed to just ordering them
around like mindless zombies but they
really didn't make it clear what the
bond between Drago and his alpha was and
why no one else was able to break that
number two hiccups mom and dad are
reunited I should have seen that this
was writing on the wall for Gerard
Butler's character dying at least he got
to dance with her one last time even
though you'd expect hiccups relationship
with toothless or with Astrid to be the
emotional core of the film I really felt
like this scene was the real cry worthy
moment how dare you make me cry Gerard
Butler and cate blanchett they were both
really good singers I didn't think that
they needed to add craig ferguson's
character in that scene I didn't think
they knew the jokes to break the tension
it was just a really nice moment they
didn't really do much of a romance
subplot but I will be interested to see
if hiccup it's a moment like that with
Astrid in the next movie and my number
one moment
toothless saves hiccup from the evil
alpha I always thought the Dragons
behaved more like dogs more than any
other animal so it totally made sense
that they incorporated pack mentality
like you have an alpha that has a level
of social control over the weaker
dragons but another dragon or dog can
come along and challenge for control
enter toothless I really like the way
they paid off the dragon lore storyline
by giving toothless all those new
abilities remember they told us he's
about the same age as hiccup so of
course he's gonna be developing new
abilities as he matures I'll say the one
big bummer the movie was is that we did
not see any other night Furies but now
it's your turn let me know in the
comments below what was your favorite
moment and where do you think they're
gonna go in the sequels just going on
the star wars metaphor they're obviously
gonna have to go to a big forest or a
jungle I think what we'll see is a new
colony of night Furies it's like during
Kung Fu Panda 3 whenever they found all
those other pandas which is kind of
funny because that was DreamWorks the
last big animated franchise so of course
they do the plot again if it worked the
first time
it's just that in this case toothless
thinks that he's the only Panda
or dragon however you want to think
about it the things that really stood
out to me as teasers for the sequels
were hiccups mom teaching him new things
about dragons hiccup charting the map
and toothless being that last night
fairy so don't be surprised if they use
all those things as story beats for that
next movie but obviously they have two
more so they're gonna have to leave some
places to go like I said though Game of
Thrones finale this weekend make sure
you check it out it's gonna be awesome
anyway but kit harington's in it so it's
gonna be a nice funny meta moment for
everyone that saw this movie my next
movie review is either gonna be 22 Jump
Street or at least transformers which is
coming next week so be sure to subscribe
to get everything and feel free to leave
me suggestions for other big movies that
you want me to do right now click here
for my Fault in Our Stars review and
click here for my Maleficent review
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
high fives